in this lesson you're going to learn how
to graph absolute value functions
with transformations we're going to go
through three examples so let's dive in
the first thing you want to know is the
basic shape of the parent function this
y
equals absolute value of x graph and the
way
you would get points for this graph is
by picking a few negative zero and a few
positives so let's go ahead and do that
so negative three when we put it into
between these absolute value bars that
tells us to make the quantity positive
it's like the distance from zero
and so this is going to be three if we
put negative two in and we get the
absolute value that gives us positive
two
negative one is one zero is zero one is
one it's always going to be positive
remember it's that distance from zero
and so on so if we plot these points
we're going to get
negative 3 3 negative 2
2 negative 1 1 0 0 1 1
2 2 3 3 and it keeps going like that and
notice how we're getting this
you know real sharp v this real sharp uh
corner here
as opposed to a quadratic where it's got
that u shape that parabola shape
so this point here where the graph bends
this is referred to as the vertex
and we're going to be looking at that
closer when we graph
absolute value graphs that are in this
form y equals a
absolute value of x minus h plus k the h
and the k is involved with shifting the
graph left and right
up and down and the a is involved with
stretching the graph
so let's talk a little bit more about
that so you see
this h here that's grouped with the x
this is going to shift it in the
x axis direction like left and right but
you want to remember that this quantity
here has actually the
opposite effect on the graph what i mean
by that
is if you had x minus one it looks like
it's
minus one you'd think it would go left
one it actually goes positive one it
goes the opposite way
whereas over here this k value this is
what's involved with shifting the graph
up and down if this is plus two it would
actually go up two if it's minus two
it'd go down two
say for example this was uh absolute
value of x plus three
see plus three you would think would be
right three right but it's actually the
opposite it goes to the left three
now the a value if it's greater than one
it's going to be a vertical stretch
meaning that the graph is going to be
narrower it's like you're pulling it in
the vertical direction
if a is between zero and one we call it
a vertical shrink or a vertical compress
it's going to
make it wider like that and if it's
negative it's going to reflect it
over the x-axis meaning it's going to
open down like that so let's jump into
the three examples and let's practice
so for number one we have y equals the
absolute value of x plus one minus three
so the first thing i like to do is i
like to find that vertex that point
where the graph bends
and this is going to shift left one and
down three so left one
down three so you're going to be right
there that's your vertex
and then the a value here you don't
actually see an a value which means that
this is really like one because one
times anything is itself
so we usually don't write the one but
you can think of it as a one here in
front
and one is like one over one right
anything divided by one is itself
and the reason i do that is because you
can think of this a value
like the slope of a line so if the slope
is 1 that means from this point we're
going to go
rise one run one and because this
absolute value graph is symmetric about
this axis of symmetry if you fold it
it's going to map to itself
because we went up one and right one we
can also go up one and
left one it's like i'm folding it over
the vertex like that
and we can continue we can go up one
over one and same thing here up one
over one and up one over one and up one
over one etcetera and so you can see
you're going to get that real
nice v shape absolute value graph now if
you're interested in finding the domain
and range
the domain is what the x values can be
and you can see that this graph is going
to the left and the right forever and
ever so the domain would be all real
numbers
but the range those are what the y
values can be and here you can see that
the lowest y can be is negative 3
or greater so for the range we'd say y
is greater than or equal to negative
three
okay let's do another example see if you
can do this one number two
it says y equals negative two times the
absolute value of x minus three
plus four so where is that vertex well
remember this one here in the
parentheses
again the absolute value bars i should
say has the opposite effect the minus 3
is actually going to shift it right 3
and the plus 4 is going to have the same
effect as that positive sign it's going
to go up positive 4. so we're going to
go right 3
up 4 1 2 3 4 right about there that's
our vertex
but this a value is negative so we know
that the
graph is going to be opening down
something like that
and the negative 2 we can think of like
the slope that's like negative two over
one so
from here i'm going to go down two one
two
and right one and i'm gonna reflect it
so i could go down two
and left one and i'll repeat that again
down to
left one from here down to uh
right one so you see how that slope but
i'm then reflecting it over this axis of
symmetry like that
so here on this one again the domain is
all real numbers
the range is going to be y is less than
or equal to
four see four is the highest or below so
we'll just write that down
positive four okay one more example if
you're enjoying this video so far
be sure to check out my algebra one and
my algebra 2 video courses as well as my
huge act math review video course and my
huge
sat math review video course i'll put a
link in the description below
but number three what we have is y
equals one third
absolute value of x plus one minus two
so what do you think for this one where
is the vertex
or you could think about it as you know
what's the transformation where's
where's the graph being shifted or
stretched
we can see this one that's grouped with
the x we talked about how that
shifts it in the x direction but it has
the opposite effect so plus one is
actually shifting at
left one this one here has the same
effect it's going to go
minus 2 that's down 2. so that's going
to put us right there that's our vertex
and we can treat the a value like the
slope right like the slope of a line
rise over run
we know it's positive so the graph is
going to open up like that
the one-third though is between zero and
one so this is going to be like a
vertical
shrink or a vertical compression it's
going to make the graph wider
but let's go ahead and graph it so from
the vertex i'm going to go up one
that's the rise run three one two three
i can repeat that up one and then
three to the right i could also go the
other direction rise one
and go left three same thing again rise
one
left three and that's because it's
symmetric about the
axis of symmetry so the graph is going
to look something like
that the domain is all real numbers and
the range is going to be y
is greater than or equal to negative 2
and you got it if you want to see
another example
follow me over to that video right there
and i'll show you some more
practice problems